did you just buy a ps4 well if one
analysts prediction comes true then you
might not be the happiest person in the
world I'm Matt and this is your
analytical gamespot news update
The Wall Street Journal reports that
analyst Damien Tong expects Sony to
release a next-generation console by the
second half of 2018 it's important to
remember that this is just a prediction
and they don't always pan out however
this is the same analyst who correctly
predicted the ps4 Pro and slim ahead of
their respective launches either way
it's likely we won't hear anything from
Sony for a while so make sure to LIKE
and subscribe to stay up to date on all
the PlayStation Information if Sony is
in fact getting ready to launch a more
powerful console next year then the
company is in an interesting position
announcing it in the near future could
undercut some of the hype for
Microsoft's upcoming project Scorpio but
it could also negatively impact sales of
the ps4 which routinely out sells the
Xbox one let us know what you think in
the comments below and if you want to
get the inside scoop on an upcoming ps4
game then check out our video on
everything we know about Call of Duty
World War 2
[Music]